how's it going bros my name is Peter
actually my playing a scary game to
scare games tonight but after that jump
scare Enix more it is I I just want to
take a chill pill to be honest anyway
welcome to some Atari dreams it's me
versus the computer this is hilarious
all right I'm the I think I'm the one to
the right all right this is pretty much
sumo wrestlers who are drunk or selfie
yeah yeah yeah I have to know which one
am I think I want alright let's do that
again all right
oh wait I'm the I'm [ __ ] lost I'm the
dark for the one all right what you
going down sucker you going down no bro
bro get off me
bro bro works every time yeah
come on get up bro bro bro I think I'm
stuck oh there we go that's better
come on I must kill anyone let her go up
this is rocky right here I'll never give
up never never again what are you
thinking of me I was [ __ ] Julia for
this it's the first one who exits arena
yes that means I I want you lose you
[ __ ] lose an idiot wait a minute
all right shut up not every time all
right
pretty good I gave all right I'm gonna
get him from behind that's nice okay you
going down sugar you going out you're
going out
alright go off me get off all right it's
your time it's my time to shine buddy I
call this one the sumo wrestling karate
kick
keep missing him all right let's see if
we can get him off the arena that'd be
awesome
where's it going are you going bro way
to go is I screwed a tamale Wow okay I
think I want that one
let's try me versus two computers
all right buddies fight fair and no
touching demolish all right put hey not
everyone against me that bad back No Oh
second damn I got what are you doing
get up get up get up
I'm pushing his penis I'm pushing
against me hey hey hey hey hey I saw you
touching me all right I guess I felt it
too all right hey come on hey let's do
one more right quite fast so I gonna win
this one okay all right for ya right
Juan you're going down aah
god damn it I lost first Oh take it easy
all right
I swallowed win this one what are you
going down sucker you going down okay
you got oh man [ __ ] wonder win one
come on this one for sure
go go they're still evil what do you
want from me go yes yes yes I am the
greatest I didn't lose the ring though I
mean I wonder if I can't go back here
come on come back [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ]
you up I'm gonna [ __ ] you up I'm up
all right let's do you can change your
lettuce and like Anisakis little areas a
kitchen party C song what's that
zoom your computer
oh all right you're going down sucker I
can stay here all day oh oh no no no yes
that was also Rui hey you lost buddy get
over it all right
that's an awesome tactic I'm just gonna
camp here come at me bro no that was
awesome
let's try that again 100 [ __ ] for me
to finally like super line I mean loud
really what ok one more [ __ ] the
longest in Trevor this one Marius way ok
when he's ready
come at me bro come on bro what ok
that's about it I wonder if you can play
more than one thing I doubt it huh oh
you can awesome
alright hey what am I doing with his bud
hey I don't like hot what hey I didn't
lose green guy lost
what I'm doing without guests buddies
discussing right buddy you're going down
going down sugar yes oh one more one
[ __ ] more I'm eating yet but alright
oh hey what happened hey hey [ __ ]
alright great I want to try another map
it's a nun different all right we're
back with soccer that's always the
pretty one alright you going down sucker
you're going now ah what are you doing
alright I swear I'll win this one if I
don't win know this one well I don't
even know I'll kill that guy I'll kill
ya get off me
that's mean I didn't do any I get off me
woman
Jesus Christ oh okay let's get up let's
get up buddy get up yeah
no no no don't you dare come now me go
get off stop
I just want to scho dare you alright
alright here's my time to shine here's
my diner okay okay I got it
no don't come near me get up he's
laughing at me get off me oh no I'm this
I don't know I place no I'm really
pissed
yes yes yes yes drip drip stupid son of
a [ __ ] hey hey okay
the main focus you got this you got it
just be calm you have a lot of time he's
not going anyway
all right turn don't [ __ ] trip don't
trip he's coming closer it's fine
go scarf go kick it something no no I
restart it I was relieving everything
all right one more wait let's see sister
a regular one and no wait wait ask to
restart the game for that
all right we're backwards slide hey come
on Brock Hey
alright whoever wins this gets the
peanut butter ate peanut butter
hey I want I want them to fall down
whoever falls down uh-oh alright well
let's try come on buddy
oh god oh god no no you better come back
here bro
better come down here come down no don't
follow Jesus Christ are you coming or
what hey come on come on fall down all
right yes yes all right just one more in
Colombia I'm waiting for you down here
I'm gonna get you I'm gonna get Jack yes
yes yes come down here now keep falling
come on stand up bro yes yes oh you're
good yes good
you're so screwed I'm gonna get you all
right and I think I'm gonna end it here
cuz I don't even know what I'm doing
hope you enjoy super 30 dreams this game
is hilarious I never leave a download
link in the description if you brought
our interested
and that's pretty much it
[Music]
let's do this son you're going down it's
just you and me buddy go